problema número 226 en la siguiente
figura si se está si se está es igual a
50 grados aquí es igual y más x bueno
estos son los grados de esta parte de
este ángulo que es este ángulo y x es
este otro de acá y estas son líneas
verticales que forman un ángulo de 90
grados muy bien yo sé que si estas
líneas son de 90 grados con respecto a
este eje con respecto a este eje
entonces van a ser paralelas entre sí
estas dos líneas de acá por lo tanto
esta línea que voy a remarcar aquí en
verde es transversal a estas líneas
paralelas y una de las propiedades de
estas líneas paralelas que son
atravesadas por una línea transversal es
que tendrán ángulos correspondientes
este ángulo z que vale 50 ya nos habían
comentado aquí que vale 50 grados está z
va a valer lo mismo de este lado aquí le
voy a llamar ye
y también vale 50 grados
estos dos ángulos son correspondientes
sé que este ángulo vale 90 grados pero
no sé cuál es el valor de este ángulo de
acá y este solo lo necesito para
encontrar este ángulo x bueno voy a
llamar a este theta y yo sé que la suma
de los ángulos internos de un triángulo
debe ser igual a 180 grados por lo que
50 más 90 que es este ángulo recto de
acá más teta es igual a 180 grados por
lo tanto 90 más 50 son 140 más theta
igual a 180 restos 140 en ambos lados y
me va a quedar que teta es igual a 40
grados esto de aquí es igual a 40 grados
muy bien yo sé que este ángulo teta más
el ángulo x me va a dar 180 grados todo
este ángulo de aquí es de 180 yo puedo
decir que 40 que es este ángulo teta más
x es igual a 180 restó 40 en ambos lados
y me queda que x es igual a 140 grados
y encontré el valor de este año 140
grados ahora me falten contra el de aquí
encontré este prima pero me falta el
ayer sin embargo puedo notar que estos
dos ángulos forman un ángulo de 180
grados aquí hay un semicírculo de
materia prima deben ser igual a 180
grados por lo que se prima vale 50 más
que igual a 180 restó 50 en ambos lados
me va a quedar que ya es igual a
130 y ahora si puedo hacer lo que me
piden hacer esta suma x más x 140 más
que 130 es igual a
270 que es mi opción de nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo